logan gilbert up on a major league mound
for the first time in his career and i'm
sure pretty excited about it he's going
to go 85 pitches today maybe five
innings for him just one start at the
triple a level he pitched five innings
in that out and gave up just one-on-one
didn't walk anybody and had five
strikeouts everybody excited about this
debut for logan gilbert logan gilbert
wines and fires first pitch in play
let's help the pitch count
see it's 96 with his first offering in
the show and it's flagged down by
hanager
this is looped out to right field as
heineker
is able to get to this one easily for
our number two 2-2 on the way fastball
swing and a fly ball into shallow center
field lewis coming in he's there and he
makes the catch and that will retire the
side what a start for logan gilbert
striding up to home plate 21 year old
outfielder jarrod celtic for the very
first time
in the big leagues wearing number 10 on
his back he's making his major league
debut tonight zach act on the mound for
the tribe
and he swings at the first pitch
right field near the line josh taylor
running out of room oh my goodness what
a play by naylor as he hung on yes he
did it was up ended into the seats
and kelnick is retired on the first big
league pitch that he sees
rat mill reyes the batter
high fly ball deep center field
sprinkles
there's the slider that stayed up keep
throwing it kid
the franimo gets loose in the great
northwest and the indians have a
one-nothing lead yes
of the season
just watch the slider it had no tilt to
it it just stays up
and it stayed middle of the plate at 81
and he did some damage
you look at fran mill and that is only
his third uh home run on the road but he
went to the deep part of the ballpark at
401 and the indians will take the lead
welcome to the big leagues my friend and
now with two down
jake bowers will be the batter
and a pace hit in the left field he
beats the shift and it's two nothing
cleveland
naylor comes home and jake bowers with a
two-out rbi single well that's what
happens the wild pitch and enables a guy
getting scoring position cesar hernandez
lead off man
begins the third
gilbert's 02.
check swing he goes around and the first
strikeout in the big league career of
logan gilbert is in the books
the first of many for number 36. one on
one out jose ramirez
there goes like that deep right field
henninger back he's out of room it's out
of here
home run number 11 for ramirez he's the
top dog in the american league and it's
four nothing cleveland
and that'll bring up centerfielder
harold ramirez
got him chasing a dirty pitch all the
way to the backstop terence has no throw
ramirez is into first one out one on for
jake bowers
he goes
another strikeout for logan gilbert
making number four the 3-2 pitch swing
and a miss and a breaking ball in the
dirt for strike three strikeout number
five for the kid logan gilbert
three strikeouts here in the top half of
the fourth inning
bottom of the fifth inning jp crawford
deleted off flying the left
is first time up
here's the one two from police act it's
swung on chopped to third third baseman
ramirez cutting across gloves and throws
and he gets him at first base here's the
pitch swing and a miss strike three
torrance down on strikes second
strikeout for please sack now the 1-0
swung on ground ball to short rosario
there throws to first in time for the
out he's got the no-hitter through five
folks zach pleesack back to work bottom
half of the sixth inning he's been
terrific
after throwing 22 pitches in the first
inning he's been in single digits
pitch-wise since he's only at 55. here's
his 1-2
swung on fly ball shallow left coming on
rosario makes the catch
and the no-hitter remains intact now
through six innings for sac please sack
zach pleesack back to the mound bottom
of the seventh inning working on a
no-hitter now the 1-1
swung on and there's a high-fly ball to
right field back on it near the corner
goes naylor he makes the catch in foul
territory
three up three down again
this time in the seventh and the no
hitter stays intact to the eighth inning
for zach plezak here tonight he's got a
chance to put his own name in that very
selective history book
line drive base hit center field looked
like it went right off the top of the
glove of rosario
seven innings no hit baseball dylan
moore the batter
high drive this is on its way
way up
the mariners get on the board they have
this ball game and it's now the indians
four and the mariners two what a shot by
moore
made it the mariners need that but what
a terrific moment
what a swing by moore he watched that
pitch all the way down through the
barrel of his bat the great follow
through and finish on a breaking ball
middle in two outs for the mariners here
in the bottom of the ninth inning that
will leave it up to kyle lewis
[Applause]
two-out walk
lewis draws his third walk tonight an
important walk
down a couple of rounds and bring up ty
france
here's the payoff
well outside
a couple of two out walks and the
mariners bring the winning run to the
plate
four pitch walking the mariners have
them loaded
up class a has walked four batters all
year he has walked three in this inning
all with two outs mariners are down to
their final lap but they've got him
loaded down by two for the time run is
on its second the winning run is on at
first base in crawford here's luis sets
of the letters the pitch swing and a
miss and the tribe escapes with a 4-2
win
in seattle
great work by brian shaw yes that was
perfect brian shaw be able to come in
just like the formula was throw some
hard cutters away save it